all right guys my last stream just got
interrupted
uh
oh my goodness
this is
guys i've had so much issues you don't
even understand i was going through my
copyrights i have over a hundred videos
that have been copyrighted over a
hundred where i either my most viewed
video i make no money on none do you
know how frustrating that is as a
creator
like do you guys have any idea
oh my gosh wait wait
oh my goodness like that is the most fro
um it makes me so mad because it's
protected under fair use
and dj freaking academics
took my video down and i'm like
my dude it's fair use
oh my goodness maybe i wonder if donovan
is he live i'm gonna see if i can call
him
because this makes me so mad is he live
um
cause i'm gonna ask him a question he
does this stuff all the time
wait
because
oh my gosh you guys you have no i i'll
even show you go to your channel
videos i go to manage videos i'll show
you my studio
and if i filter if i filter my videos by
copyright
claims watch this watch this
these are all the videos i have
copyright claims on
92 videos
do you know how frustrating that is
and let's let's let's organize them by
views
a hundred thousand views
i've this i've filed i've gotten an
escrow like i followed the copyright
thing so many times never works
this one they threatened to take down so
i just dropped dicks i don't i don't
want to strike
this is a hundred thousand
and usually so this would be probably
like a hundred thousand views
usually
so if i make a 10 000 view video
um let me find a 10 000 view video see
what i make on that
i'm just going to show you how much
money i lose based on
this [ __ ] drives me crazy so a seven
minute ten thousand view video
um
i make
that's 20 minutes
okay this one's about 10 minutes let's
see oh but i just started making money
on it
see actually most of my most
okay fine this one's 13 minutes so it's
a little bit longer okay
but it got
let me find it let me find it
um
oh my gosh i'm trying to find it i was
just looking at it it was an abbott and
preach video that i reacted to
oh here we go okay so this is 15k
and i made
how much money on it so roughly i made
about
100 bucks right
so for 15 000 so let's add all this up
[Music]
100 000
plus
thirty-seven thousand
plus twenty-seven thousand
plus fifteen thousand
plus thirteen thousand
plus twelve thousand
plus eleven thousand
plus ten thousand
this is why i stopped doing rap
reactions because it was so frustrating
and my account was like
blowing up it was blowing the f up
i got like 10 000 subscribers in a month
but it just didn't even make sense
because i was making no freaking money
at it
like it was like them i would get so
many views and no money
and i was just like this is so freaking
frustrating
that
okay so
four thousand okay
so
oh wait i shouldn't have added
i'm gonna subtract like 15 000 views
because i'm only going to do the
ten minute videos
um so let's just subtract twenty
thousand
so that's two hundred sixty thousand
views divide that by fifteen thousand
roughly
times a hundred
it's like two thousand dollars
i missed out on which might not be a lot
to you guys but that's a lot to me like
um and it's just so freaking frustrating
because
it's because it's like i i'm
i'm doing according to youtube i can do
this like youtube tells me
i can i can and then fricking
so if if that's the case then why do i
always get copyrighted all the time
um and you knew dg academics well and
that's the thing like he knows that fair
use is
is allowed but here's the problem when
you're a small content creator you can't
do [ __ ]
so
then you're forced to take down a video
that you should be allowed to react to
but i'm not a big content creator i
don't know anyone at youtube
so
so what what am i supposed to and like
honestly if i really went through all of
those videos that like i got copyrighted
this is probably thousands of dollars
worth of views
do you know how frustrating that is
because some of these videos are like
like all of these videos copyright
copyright copyright
like it is the most frustrating thing to
put so much work into this channel and
have over a hundred videos get
copyrighted all the time
sorry i'm like bitching but this is like
the most frustrating thing
and i just see like this one is pending
removal so
because because i i filed the copyright
i did this one in march or may
so i have to take it down now
otherwise i get a copyright strike you
know
and so that's a big company so now i
have to because i i tried to do the
right thing and i tried to say hey i
deserve the money from this because i'm
reacting to this and this is trans like
transforming the content
and i requested to like get the money
from it then they said oh no we're just
gonna take your [ __ ] down otherwise
we're gonna give you a copyright strike
like that that is so freaking
frustrating
and oh my god sorry i know i'm just like
bitching right now but
a lot of times i do this [ __ ] and i feel
like i'm doing it for nothing
because
like it just doesn't seem to like matter
like it just seems like
no matter what i do
i get copyright copyright copyright
um
and like to be honest it makes me not
want to do youtube it makes me want to
go to a different platform like
tick-tock because
they don't freaking take all of my money
like copyright is much more
so this was in february i was at 10 000
subscribers i got 10 000 subscribers in
about like three weeks from the rap
reactions
and i kept doing them until like march
but i made no money for three months it
was like my highest views was my lowest
revenue so it was like
why do it
i don't know sorry
again sorry i'm bitching it's just like
i lately i've been
it's been very difficult
for me on social media
like it's just it's been hard like my
rent is high in london my expenses are
much higher
and i'm really trying to like put out
the best content but when i put in all
this work and i it's like i get no money
out of it i want to kill somebody
and especially when it's these big ass
content creators
like like dj academics like you know
that i i can react to your [ __ ]
legally
but you're gonna copyright me like that
is so frustrating and i don't know if
it's him or his team or whatever and i'm
gonna try and email him but it's like
like i ha
i don't know god it's just oh my god
this stuff gets me going
about reaction to donovan no i'm going
to that's actually
if he texts me back that's what i'm
going to call him about because
and i thought it was um 20 seconds then
i'm finding out it's like every 15
seconds you have to pause it i'm like
that is so ass especially on these like
songs oh my gosh
okay anyways i'm done bitching what do
you guys want me to react to
oh my god i'm so
oh my god
god that just like gets me my blood
boiling boiling when i look at that
oh it gets my blood boiling oh my god it
gets my blood boiling
my most a hundred thousand views no
money none
so
okay
academics doesn't let anyone use his
content
i i know but you're
under fair use if you could like
i just don't understand why because like
here fair use youtube
look at
fair use there are three factors when it
comes to fair use the purpose of
character blah blah blah the nature of
the copyrighted work the amount
of so i only did like a 10 minute clip
out of that whole interview
the effect of the use yeah so
[Music]
i don't know oh god it makes me mad
oh my god this [ __ ] makes me so mad
like do you know what's like to have a
hundred videos that i didn't even get
paid for at all like oh my god
how much do i earn from youtube
oh my god with this copyright [ __ ]
lately not enough not enough oh my god
this month i think i maybe made like 300
bucks
um luckily i make money off of instagram
and tick tock so like
if i take all of them into account i
might make like
the most i've ever made in a month is
four thousand um last month was really
low because i was traveling and i just
didn't have time to like do everything
so like maybe a thousand
like something i would say like maybe
like around a thousand last month but
i think i was like 2000 in november it's
not a lot guys um the only reason i'm
able to do what i'm doing is because i
saved up a lot of money for my old sales
job
um like my parents don't give me money
at this point like they they would i
think if i was really struggling but
um
yeah i have like expenses and stuff and
it's
um
yeah it's very frustrating how much i
earn from tick tock it really depends on
the month um and if i get a brand deal
so this month
i'm probably gonna make
um i made one
for let's see i made i took a 345
i'm probably gonna make like 800 bucks
off of brand deals um
and then maybe like
uh
three to five hundred bucks off of views
between tick tock and youtube and
instagram
like each so like each one will be like
like in in november my most i got paid
the most off of instagram and per view i
actually do get the most off of
instagram
um but i'm not very good about finding
brand deals and stuff because in my head
i'm like if i just keep the content
going i think that's more important than
finding brand deals like
at this point
um i don't know
how do i make money off of instagram you
can do
instagram you can do
how do i put it um
let me i have this brand actually just
emailed me when do you need
do you need the draft
um
so this
sorry what did it say um
[Music]
instagram you right now only certain
people can make money off of it you have
to be selected but you get bonuses for
tick tock reels
and it's very good pay but it caps so i
can only make a thousand two hundred per
month off of views total so i just post
a million of my tick tocks and hope one
takes off and sometimes i don't
sometimes they do
i might actually have to get a real job
no i might i paid so
basically
i paid six months rent so i have my rent
paid until
um november december january february
march april so until april i have my
rent paid
um
so i just i basically just have to make
enough money for the second six months
of my rent
um
and i think i probably could pay one or
two but i still need to like live and
stuff so
yeah it's gonna be
so i just i'm trying to work like really
hard at this but it's really frustrating
when you work so hard it's something
just to like be like copyright left
copyright right like a hun
it's just oh my god i could talk about
this [ __ ] for days because it makes me
so mad
so freaking mad
um but no i definitely i actually just
applied for um working for a youtube
channel the other day because
and i have to pay taxes soon
so that's a whole other
oh god
um
but then why the whining i'm not okay
sir then get off my
get off my thing um
start posting more no that's what i'm
doing like that's why i'm live today
but the problem is like it's just
frustrating when i
i don't mind like doing more and like
working harder at something but it's
very frustrating when you're working
hard it's something just to get like the
money like taken from you
every single like time
okay guys put put something i should
react to in the chat
sorry i think i just bitched for like
20 minutes he sorry
um
um
um
okay um what should i react to guys
let's see
anything looks interesting
um
there's a music video
[Music]
totally not marked copyright video
um
why men and women can't be friends okay
i like that one
i don't know what the duke and john
versus rolo drama is
okay
all right i'm gonna do my intros just
because i'm gonna clip these later all
right
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to why men and women
can't be friends before i start do not
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos before i start you already know
if you've watched two or more of my
videos and you do not subscribe me and
you we have beef
beef
so hit that subscribe button it
literally takes you two seconds it's
below hit it
and hit the notification turn
notifications on that way you're
notified every time i'm live and i
upload
here we are at the um
utah state university library
for some interviewing
to ask people
if they believe that men and women can
be just friends
so let's go inside and see what we can
find
do you believe that men and women can be
just friends yes yeah of course
yes i do
yeah yes yes yeah
um i think
[Laughter]
it'd be hard to do
yes
i mean we're all men i know so of course
we're going to have those feelings and
we can
we can be content with just friendship
but and we can be silent
regarding those feelings but we're going
to have them
okay
i have interesting views on this i think
men and women can be friends
but but but
usually it starts as one or one of the
people is interested so the girl's
interested in the guy the guy is
interested in the girl or they live by
each other or work together that's what
i've found like they can but it has to
start with either like living by each
other working together or being in the
same friend group
or one of them was interested and one of
them rejected the other
i don't believe so no
i guess what i'm saying is no okay good
girl
okay we'll walk with you do you believe
men and women can be just friends
um yeah yes
yes
okay do you have any guy friends
right now you're just friends with yeah
oh yeah um all my best friends are guys
dave
trevor trevor
taylor mulford bobby yeah how long have
you known trevor two years of those guy
friends do you think it's funny i did
the same interview on a christian campus
and so many people said yes even the
guys even the guys said yes give them
secretly like you
and be honest probably yeah do you think
that guy is interested in you
yes
okay maybe you can only be just friends
in high school because most guys won't
just be my friend i i think over a
certain age it starts to go away but i i
think i do think guys and girls can be
friends like under a certain age
but once you get older not really would
dave hook up with you if if you gave him
the chance
well yeah do you think trevor liked you
yeah
yes
would he hook up with you if you wanted
hook up yeah
so he likes you
so what you're saying is men and women
can't be friends no we can be friends
but you're just friends but he likes you
yes
so it's a one-sided friendship
that was
one
instance if she wanted to hook up would
you hook up oh totally
that is so funny
[Music]
don't be sarcastic i need the truth
seriously yeah all right there we go all
right that's perfect okay cut cut
because of physical attraction it's not
possible okay but you said i just want
to be just friends
yeah
now do you
literally believe that he is not
interested in you at all
yes that's what i'm talking about
as we can see
after interviewing everyone
in the library um it is impossible for
men and women to be just friends
and under no circumstances
can it happen
um
that's a wrap
i mean i
um i've known women who i've had a
mutual lack of attraction to and it was
liberating
she might have been in the friend zone
because i i've been in the i've been
friendzoned before by a guy where i like
liked him and he didn't like me back
um
that was funny though oh my gosh that
was very funny
um okay guys oh shoot wrong one um
you already know do not forget to
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification bell okay bring it
hit it right now
um and i will talk to you guys next time
okay just you guys know i do that at the
end because i'm gonna clip these later i
know i've said this oh no no not my
email not my email
oh god okay
what should i react to next um
okay um
you can help solve my problem with my
channel
please
oh my god i'm begging you please solve
this problem please
like
i
beg i swear to god no i'm not leaving
i'm not m
guys i'm not leaving
i just do that at the end
oh i just do that so i can clip it
i'm sorry i know it's confusing
it's complicated
okay this looks fun um
um
sex is a weapon this looks interesting
okay
as you guys know i'm about to do my
intro okay
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm gonna
be reacting to sex as a weapon the rules
of modern dating and understanding women
quote unquote it's complicated before i
start do not forget to subscribe to the
channel ring that notification bell okay
ring it you already know if you have
watched two or more of my videos and you
do not subscribe me and you we have
beef
beef okay all right
[Music]
is it easier for a man or a woman to
acquire sex
uh no i think it's kind of equal you
think it's equal
oh no oh no no no let me ask you this
what is the longest that a man's ever
made you wait for sex
okay so they make them wait right so
women typically make men weights so
isn't it safe to conclude that it's
easier for women to you know control the
sex
you know you know we control it yeah
right in other words women sleep with
who they want men sleep with who they
can right
yes okay so basically if it's harder for
a man to get sex should women be
surprised that guys have lower standards
for sex than women
no but biologically men need it
more than women
who is more likely to influence the
behavior of the opposite sex men or
women men men
are you more likely to see women going
to men's night or men going to ladies
nights
duh
duh although i
women will go when a game's playing at a
bar
are you more likely to see women going
to men's night or men going to ladies
night
women going to man's night man going to
ladies night
well wouldn't that prove that women are
more likely to influence men's behavior
no women going to man's night that
sticks to my first carson women typical
i mean do they even have men's night
actually they would never invite you to
their man's night does the fact that
ladies nights exist prove that if you
control the women my ex-boyfriend
i don't think he would have
let me go he didn't really do boys
nights but i don't think he would have
been invited you also control the
men yep
okay so very true okay so women
influence men's behavior i mean do women
do women line up to go to clubs full of
men
no no men line up to go to close school
women right okay so then doesn't that
prove that if you control the women you
also control the men you get them to
show up and buy drinks and spend money
so women are more likely to influence
the behavior of men right yeah okay
yeah i guess in that industry okay women
often want to fix or change men's
behavior do you think it's possible to
change men's behavior without first
changing women
[Music]
no no we've just established the press
that's a good question wait so
women have to change in order for men to
change
i guess yeah sort of premise that uh
women influence men's behavior right
yeah so i guess so is it true that men
are [ __ ] because women date [ __ ]
yeah
yeah that's true
guilty the women have the right to come
do women have the right to complain
about men being [ __ ] when they're
enabling that behavior yeah no
why do you say why why because if you're
enabling it then it's stupid that's true
bringing you on more problems more
shitty men okay is it easier for a man
or woman to acquire sex
a choir what do you mean is it is it
easier for a man or woman to get sex
it's easier for a woman yeah since it's
harder for men should women be surprised
that guys have lower standards for sex
than women no
do women have the privilege of being
more picky because they have more
options
yeah
who regulates the sex in a relationship
the man or the woman
the woman
right what's the longest a man's ever
made you wait
i don't wait for [ __ ]
so in order to change men's behavior
don't you first have to change women's
behavior
we try to with uh what's it called uh
you know when the guys dress up naked
with a little thing on their thing
what's called when they're they put on a
show and it's a guy
chippendales exactly that's what we try
to do isn't it true that men are
[ __ ] because women date [ __ ] uh
kinda actually because girls like
i've heard so many guys tell me that i
was nice until i realized women don't
like the nice guy so i became an [ __ ]
i've heard that
so many times so many times
which is like you know physical and also
mental
well i mean women like dick but they
also like dicks they like kind of the
dicks guys oh dick of attitude not
exactly exactly well you guys don't care
about them okay
isn't it true that i
that's so true because
i'm gonna just tell you the psychology
and i'm not saying it makes sense but
i'm just gonna explain it if you're a
guy and
i i've
had a guy just be all in on me like he
met me and i was like yeah i don't drink
um at the time like i was like i don't
really go out i'm
kind of i just like work on my youtube
channel i like to travel like that sort
of thing and he was just so a hundred
percent in on me
and i was my thought was like
respectfully why
i'm cool don't get me wrong but like you
barely know me like why are you this
dust like it came across desperate
because i'm like you barely know me and
you're all in so it makes me just think
like one you do this to every single
girl you meet and two it's not like real
like you don't even know me and you
already have these feelings
so
that's why sometimes we prefer the
[ __ ] because
like if a guy is 100 in on you just so
quick it's like
sounds so bad because it is but it's
like like why
like it's just
like don't you want to get to know me
better to decide like why are your
standards just crazy low
um that's just how it comes off sorry
men are [ __ ] because women date
[ __ ]
yes
so women influence men's behavior do
they have the right to complain about
the way men behave
no
that's not true at all but i mean if
women influence men's behavior i mean if
guys are nice guys they get friend zones
so does that explain why guys are
[ __ ] or bad boys because that's what
women respond to
not necessarily i think to each his own
i think women who
look for bad boys they're just bad on
their own and i mean
i mean that's i don't know that's a
tricky question because
it's vice versa i feel like it kind of
feeds off each other the stigma about
men and women it feeds off of each other
you look for what you want
each other men are supposed to be and if
you complain about a bad boy or a bad
girl then it's your fault because that's
what you're looking for in the beginning
why that's true that's true look at
every situation i've been in with a guy
that
like he didn't treat me right i will
genuinely say that [ __ ] was my own fault
that [ __ ] was my own fault i signed up
for it i do not feel bad for me why do
women often choose to make lists of what
they want in a relationship rather than
what they bring to the table
oh that's so true
that's a hard one
um
just like one in that car that has the
fast power the horsepower tin and
windows the top down
but you go in and your credit gets you
the
kia rio you know
that girl's funny
make that list to hopefully aim it kia
rio's a damn good car i have a kia rio
06 180 000 miles for the record still
running
why do women often attack a man's
masculinity when they don't get what
they want
because they want to belittle them
why is sex typically the first thing
that's withheld when women don't get
what they want
because that's what it's all about
what does that say about women because
men can be controlled through sex that's
why actually contribute to a
relationship
it depends on the women
isn't that the same thing as using sex
as a weapon against men yes
why do women often attack a man's
masculinity when they don't get what
they want
[Music]
i don't think i'd do that but i'm not
saying i'm not saying you do that but
why do i lie to you or if a lot of women
do it is to it's because sometimes men
don't like to show their emotions so
they kind of want to see that
man bad cry sort of like come down from
being macho and just i'm a human i have
feelings too
okay why do women want men to show their
emotions when the man's feelings are
typically the last ones considered and
are often made fun
[ __ ] make me of
because we want to know they're there
you know it's like
we gotta know you have it
this is so bad but when i think about it
it's like we want to know you guys care
and i think sometimes like when girls
say like they want a guy that's
emotionally available we're like oh we
want we want to see that he cares about
me he loves me
but the problem is
if you get too emotional
and you just it gets to the point where
you're like
kind of a [ __ ]
like we're not we're not attracted to
that so i don't know what the line is
it's tough because
i don't think the solution is never talk
to your girl about your emotions ever
but
i i think the solution is just tougher
men
in general but we also don't want a
society where men
can't feel like they can talk about
their feelings ever like that's not a
good solution
um
but i don't know the
it's somewhere in the middle
if we ever needed it to show we need to
know that it's there like
why is sex typically the first thing
that's withheld when women don't get
what they want
that's all that men want so what does
that say about what women actually
contribute to a relationship
it says that
we hold the power and we consent the the
sexual acts you know so isn't isn't that
the same thing as using sex as a weapon
against men
it is but we don't have nothing else to
use against them
we're not stronger than them we you know
why is sex typically the first thing
that's withheld when women don't get
what they want manipulation
what does that say about what women
actually contribute to a relationship
i mean
that doesn't mean [ __ ] sex doesn't mean
[ __ ] about what once again if it didn't
mean anything why would be the first
thing that's withheld
manipulation it's just a manipulation
it's a tactic it's the easiest one to
bring forward isn't that the same thing
as using sex as a weapon against men
yeah
it's the first thing that we're there
because that's the first thing the man
wants when we first meet a woman we
don't really want to get to know her the
first thing we want we want sex
well what does that say about what women
actually contribute to a relationship
okay
oh that's so funny when we see a woman
you're not looking like oh it's gonna be
my wife you looking like damn she fine
i'll [ __ ] her
what is the longest you've gone without
having sex
a month
20 20
years is the longest you've gone by
choice without having sex a month so do
jail sentences count
a year
what is the longest by choice by choice
20 years and then two after that without
having sex a year
who is more likely to lie about how long
they've gone without sex men or women
men
don't men lie about getting more and
women lie about getting less yeah yeah
why is that
because it's the it's the stereotypes
that they have against women that you
shouldn't be having sex a lot who is
more likely to lie about how long
they've gone without sex men or women
who's
i don't know they both lie for different
reasons i think
don't men lie about getting more and
women lie about getting less yes yeah
why are women who sleep around seen as
[ __ ] while men who sleep around are
seen as stuff because it's easy for
women to get sex like if i
if i really wanted to have sex all i
have to do is go outside find a guy and
be like look i'm in this apartment to
myself
pull up it'd be so easy
on the other hand
men i don't think that's the case
because of the world and the and the
stereotypes it's society and how they
feel like a man who gets more as a
player and a woman who gets more as a
[ __ ]
like a men's value increases in a
woman's value decreases yeah could it be
because it's easy for a woman to be a
[ __ ]
uh i mean it is easier
could it be because it's easier for a
woman to be a [ __ ]
yeah but we also can get money from it
too
what's the difference between
what's the difference between shaming a
woman for being a [ __ ] and shaming a man
for being an incel in other words why
are women shamed for having too much sex
while men are shamed for not getting any
sex
i guess i don't know men are shamed for
getting sex too
i shame men for getting too much sex
men are shamed but
this is how it is like women will say oh
you're such a player you're this you're
that
but here's the problem here's the issue
women will say that they'll say that but
they'll still sleep with them like
they'll they'll complain that the guy's
hooking up with everyone but they'll
still sleep with the
women have a choice to be a [ __ ] but a
man doesn't have a choice to be an incel
what's in itself involuntarily celibate
okay
like specifically i feel like guys are
ashamed when it's more clear that a girl
is not interested and they keep going
for it like when it's too much
why are men shamed for not being able to
get sex but also shame for trying to get
sex
it's all about your approach
i mean isn't that isn't that kind of
damned if you do damned if you don't
like i mean i feel like it is for both
sexes it depends on your approach
something this is very vulgar
and other men approach like real
gentlemen what are the characters
that's code for the guys i'm interested
in
basically the hot guy if you're hot
approach me if you're not don't draw six
of a gentleman
um
to me is uh not lying about nothing you
know telling them what it is
and whatever they want to do with that
that's what they can do with that what
would you call the female equivalent of
a gentleman
a lady
a lady
what are the characteristics of a lady
respect honor
that's about it should a woman who
doesn't act like a lady expect a man to
act like that's interesting he said
respect honor that's okay guys the more
i've listened to like men's content the
more i've seen that's what men care
about more than anything is just like
being honored and respected
so they'll like a man will overlook a
lot
a lot for a girl if he feels like she
honors and respects him like
he'll over
he'll overlook a past he'll overlook
like
i don't know he'll overlook um
maybe her not being the most attractive
girl he can get like that's that's what
i've noticed like if that girl really is
down for that guy and he he can feel
that like he'll overlook a lot a lot of
the time gentlemen
no
what is the difference between
respecting a woman and making her feel
special versus the guy just pandering to
her every need
say that one more time what is the
difference between respecting a woman
and making her feel special versus the
guy just pandering to her every need
what is the difference
i might give her what she needs not what
she wants
oh that was a good answer good answer
sir
um
does she need her nails done or does she
want her nails done
if she wants them done
i might not
if women weren't slut-shamed and were
actually celebrated for being a [ __ ]
would they still play hard to get
yes why
because you can get more money out of
them if you play hard to get could it be
because women use sex to get power
i do not
to me i don't like accepting big gifts
for men because it's always like what do
you want in return and i don't ever want
to feel like i owe a guy anything
so
i don't know
like
my boyfriend of a year literally offered
me like 20 grand once and i said no
because
i just i don't know i felt weird
accepting that money i don't know
some of them yes yeah are women more
interested in love or power
depends on the person
are men more likely to use power to get
sex or are women more likely to use sex
to get power
sex to get power
do you think women are more interested
in love or power
power
really that's interesting
okay um
if all the men in the world were gay how
would women get power
by
creating and being they would
yeah we'd have to
build [ __ ] basically a dominant
force in society and government and
leadership and influence since men
aren't all gay where would women
actually get their power from
since men aren't all gay where do women
actually get their power from
we said it earlier with the sex
control so can we agree that women get
their power by manipulating straight men
i mean don't women don't women have
power because men give it to them
um
oh my god that's such an interesting
question like what do you mean by power
is he talking about like power in a
relationship that would be true
power
in
congress i would say for sure some of it
like a lot of the
policies
are directed like towards women
um
interesting okay oh wait okay
if all the men in the world were gay how
would women get power
she
said it i don't say that one more time
if all the men in the world were gay how
would women get power
since men since man i don't [ __ ] know
money [ __ ] since men aren't all gay
where do women actually get their power
from
they [ __ ] so can we agree that women
get their power by manipulating straight
men
it depends on the individual but yeah
okay don't women get power by using sex
as a weapon against men
don't women get power because men give
it to them
women are the world women women women
have power only most men only want to
take the power because they want to take
from the from women if god was a man a
woman or an animal and walked up to me
i'm going to go to the woman because i
believe god is god as a woman so i'm the
wrong person next that quest
okay they got power regardless well
right we can't be born without a woman
well right but women can't conceive
without a man
right that's true but
don't y'all read the bible and the bible
say that uh the virgin mary had a time
yeah that's what she no
she had a child without a man
what power but that happened one time
has it ever happened again since then
they said that a snake talked to adam
and eve oh my god
sir i think you're losing i think you're
losing the point of the question i ain't
seen a snake talk since i've been alive
so at the end of the day men give women
their power right so aren't women
fighting the hand that feeds them when
they say men are toxic man ain't [ __ ]
damn
damn that was a good point
definitely
is that smart i mean are the women
smarter if they're doing that
no it's not smart but it's sort of like
a dog it's like dogs are messy dogs make
you know a lot of noise but at the same
time everybody wants them it's they
still that cute cuddly moment so it's
same with men and finally what advice
would you give to the men that don't
trust women
you don't trust yourself
and you need the star trek okay
people are shitty on both sides men lie
to women and women lie to mad it goes it
goes both ways yourself so you can trust
her
because not all women are bad
um okay that was really interesting i'm
gonna have to react to this more okay
guys you already know
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel bring that notification bell let
me know what video i should react to
next time in the comments follow my
instagram just dot pearly things and i
will talk to you guys next time
okay guys i'm still going i just do that
so i can cut these later
so i can cut these later and do like a
oh my god i need to stop opening that
um
guys i'm not leaving i i know every time
i'm sorry should i react to another one
that was interesting
um
um
okay put
should i react to next should be earned
not given freely yeah okay
um should i write to another one that
was actually really interesting i'm
gonna do it again um
that was a really great interview
guy dumps girlfriend for being too tall
it's just gonna hit close to home
dumps
okay
all right i'm gonna do my intro as you
guys know
um
it might be that okay
oh actually i can do yours next i just
got your text
um
i'm gonna do this one but some send me
the link on um or the title if you text
me the title i'll do it
next okay
i'm gonna do my intro okay what up guys
welcome to the just pearly things
youtube channel today i am going to be
reacting to guy dum's girlfriend for
being too tall and lives to regret his
decision before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos and as
you guys know if you've watched two or
more of my videos and you have not
subscribed we have beef
beef all right okay
let's go also follow my instagram just
dot pearly things just dot pearly things
shoot we're gonna be late let's go
okay
seriously
you're really wearing heels gina yeah i
just bought these aren't they so cute no
they make it look like a giant he dumped
her i'm sorry respectfully she is out of
his league she's out of his league
respectfully respectfully too tallest it
is i don't need you looking any taller
just take them off
but
i i didn't bring any of the shoes to her
this is gonna be so embarrassing
[Music]
embarrassing sir chill
guys you cannot change your height there
is no point
like there is no point in stressing over
how tall you are because you literally
cannot change it
i love being tall i would not
give that up for the world
i'm i'm 5 11. i'm almost 6 foot and i
swear to god
if you're short just own it there are
girls that will still date you even if
you're short or even shorter than them
but if you're insecure about it they
will literally
leave
hey matt it's good to see you man hey
you're my new girlfriend rosa
pleasure to meet you rosa wow
you're a lucky man
she's lovely
do you guys have any more wine glasses
yeah i'll get
them so what's up man all right are you
seeing anyone i don't know oh um
no one special
sorry can one of you help me i can't
reach the wine glasses
sure
what the
they are really hard to reach
we might need a chair
i i can help you
there you go you helped have long arms
thanks you must be a mets a friend
oh what the
the audacity sir she's so hot
my friend
nice to meet you
cheers to uh matt's friend
[Music]
are you trying to do embarrass me
no i was only trying to help well don't
unless you like people thinking you're a
giant
okay i don't this isn't real
i'm not even trying to say this but i
have never had an issue dating
due to my height to be honest like
for the most part guys have not cared
the most when i was in college i swear
to god five guys were the ones that
approached me the most the most
[Laughter]
[Applause]
okay let's do it all right gina
oh my god
giraffe
giraffe
crane
skyscraper
giants yes yes that's it
babe isn't that so funny we're just
talking about that
you really think this is all funny
they are laughing at you
not with you what the
bruh
bruh
wait
hey yeah what's going on i like tall
women okay this is what i found out with
this is my theory with dating okay
this is my theory with dating if a guy
is like
with tall guys i've noticed if a guy's
like
six two to six three like six one to six
three ish he prefers the five five girls
i i'm not his preference usually but if
i meet a guy that's like six four six
five and up
they like tend to like go for girls that
are like my height like 5 11.
um that this is just what i found no
data just anecdotal evidence but
yeah i think it's a thing for like those
guys because i think the height
difference isn't as crazy
is everything okay of course it's not
what the [ __ ] did you see how the role
is this terrible acting lasting you for
being a giant i'm sorry i i didn't take
it like that
what if i took my heels off you still
look like a giant what the
sis you can you can go get get you get
you a tall man you can't i really tried
to make this work gina i i told myself
okay
she's a little tall
but so what
she treats you good she cares a lot
about you
but i'm sorry
i
i just can't
tonight really confirmed it all for me
what
all of this just because how tall i am
oh my god this is what men go through
daily i'm sorry guys this isn't fair to
you but this is what you go through
daily
well that's too bad then isn't it
you know
i'm such a good girlfriend to you
and all you care about is my height
one day you'll realize
it's not what's on the outside that
matters
it's what's on the inside
leave him what that he said not to me
take it
matt breaks up with gina and leaves her
there heartbroken
before long matt moves on and starts a
relationship with their new girl where's
he getting these baddies
[Music]
things seem to be going great
until he starts to notice that she
doesn't treat him as good as gina had
she wouldn't pay attention to him and
was always distracted
and she never even wanted to be seen in
public with him
she made him feel like he was worthless
the same way he made gina feel
matt quickly began to miss his
ex-girlfriend
they never appreciate us till we're gone
i'm not sad i'm not sad at all a couple
months go by and then one day he happens
to run into gina
hi reservation under the name gina sure
just give me a minute gina
wow i
i can't believe it's you oh
hey matt
how have you been
um i've
i've been better actually
my uh
girlfriend i just broke up so
things have been kind of hard oh no i'm
so sorry that's okay
it was probably for the best
she didn't treat me the way
the way you did
you know i
thinking about you a lot lately
do you think we could
maybe try again
excuse me
hey you mind taking a picture for me
please oh uh yeah yeah sure
i told you you could do better sis i
told you come here babe
oh
is she or he's he's way hotter he's way
hotter
she's my girlfriend
isn't she beautiful
yeah and he doesn't care and he doesn't
care
but
doesn't it bother you being with someone
you know
so much taller than you
are you kidding me
absolutely not look man for me it's not
what's on the outside that matters but
what's on the inside and look great
things come in tall packages
thank you
so uh
do y'all do know each other from
somewhere yes no no no that's like the
she's like don't do this don't tell my
friend
he was he was just my friend
your table's ready oh great
good to see you matt
bruh she's just borderline let's be
honest the average girl in the united
states is 150 pounds
i'm sorry
if you're in shape as a girl and you
have a nice face you're above average
you guys might not like it
it might not be a fun reality it's just
true
ellie stop barking
oh my gosh oh no
sorry
hey dar man fam make sure to subscribe
to my channel okay that was a fun video
that was a fun video
all right tallulah
oh wait no i think it's the feminine
truth that's her channel
feminine
truth
um
oh wait wait all right guys thank you
for watching the video um do not forget
to subscribe to the channel ring that
notification bell
um that way you're going to be notified
of my daily videos and i will talk to
you guys next time feminine truth sorry
guys i do the
guys you should go subscribe to
lula's channel
um
this actually is very i'm always so
jealous of people that have like clean
looking channels because my channel is a
mess it is literally a mess
um
ellie needs to come in for the reactions
she does sometimes but i don't feel like
pulling a chair in her for her today
uh let's see
delete your instagram from five minute
video okay
wait i gotta do my intro because i'm
gonna cut these later okay
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube
hold on let me see why my dog's barking
i'm going to be right back
i'm going to be right back
hold on
ellie what
style what are you what
what's up
child you wanna come in you're gonna
react with me
okay
come here come here come here
okay i'm gonna ellie's gonna join right
now
come here ellie come here
ah come
here all right come here
come here
we're gonna
we're gonna set you here okay you're
gonna sit down i'm gonna adjust my
camera so you'll be in it
this will be fun
this will be fun
um
uh okay we're gonna
adjust the camera so ellie can be in
can i
this is my problem i think i need to
i forgot how i controlled this
all right you ready come here come here
gonna sit on my lap no oh god no okay
well
let's see that the problem is the height
difference
okay well i guess she's just gonna sit
here because
sorry guys
technical difficulties
because she's too
um
[Music]
wait wait
oh my god what if i put it here hold on
hold on we're gonna
i'm gonna be very surprised if this
actually looks normal
hold up hold up
okay
i put her here
put me we're gonna try this this is like
a test and if it doesn't work we won't
do it again
but
do we like this angle
nope too much
oh god oh god this is such a struggle oh
okay
ah
okay wait
wait
oh my god oh my god that was something
of it
oh my god oh my god
okay
okay i'm gonna move it a little more
this way okay
so um
do we like this
uh okay wait
dewey are we a fan of this let's see in
my comments
um
[Music]
okay
what my dog is ugly you're ugly you
don't even have a profile picture johnny
green
get out of here
no insulting my [ __ ]
okay
okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel today i am
going to be reacting to the feminine
truth delete your instagram for him
before i start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos if you
have watched two or more of my videos
and you do not subscribe me you we have
beef
beef also this is my dog ally she's
joining me today
okay
about instagram
[Music]
so why do you have instagram
well i think we all know as women you
have instagram to
get validation you want validation you
want to know you look good tallulah
i have instagram to make money
you wanted other guys to message you but
it's true that's true if a cat if a cute
guy messages me i would not be mad i
would not you want likes
you want um see if there's a better guy
out there maybe i don't know but is it
really sensible or respectful
to do this when you're already dating a
high-value guy
once you are with him like this
high-value guy
like you are his
that's just it like you are here okay
and this is what girls don't understand
when you are dating somebody somebody
you are a representation of him
you are so if you get your ass all over
instagram like that's embarrassing to a
guy like that's really embarrassing
because you're basically advertising and
saying
i'm like trying to get out of here
basically
you are not
anyone else's you are not out there in
the marketplace looking for the next
person right
you are you belong to him he belongs to
you you belong to him whatever way you
want to say it
and i think that this video really is
about explaining how
once you are with this high-value guy
what you should do of your instagram and
quite honestly there's nothing more to
say other than
in the bin it needs to go
it needs to go the reason i need to go
is because it is
look we all know as women that when we
post up a photo of ourselves
we like if i was to ask you
i'm a middle ground type of
person i do think that if it's a problem
in your relationship you should be
willing to delete a piece of social
media however i don't think every girl
that has instagram is like out there
fishing i think if you have instagram
you should be 100 comfortable
him looking through your messages you
should not have anything on there like
in your messages
and you can even turn them off like you
can turn it off so you can't get
messages from anybody
so i don't know don't don't be doing
shady [ __ ] girls why are you posting
that photo of you up in this dress or
tight jeans or a bikini or whatever
you're going to say oh cause i look nice
or oh because of this that the other
it's for me it's for me no it's not for
you and you know it's not for you
there's other people if it was for you
you'd be like they're taking photos of
yourself and that that's it that's all
you'd need and you could just look at
them right if you're dating like some
low value guy that does nothing for you
in your life and that you're not even
happy with go ahead but realistically
just get rid of the guy and move forward
with your life but you know fine do it
but if you're someone who's a high value
guy and
and yeah if you're the son who's a high
value guy and you are still behaving
this way
this guy is going to like lit this guy's
going to say to you like don't do that
or if you do or he might just leave he
might not even tell you that's the thing
like guys like that that have options
they're they're not gonna give you a
warning
they're just gonna leave again like i'm
gonna be gone
it is incredibly disrespectful like if i
was a guy and i had
a girl posting up all these photos of
herself like on nights out and like look
at me here and look at me and my tight
jeans and my bikini and it's the same
thing like i would want to date a guy
that's posting
gym selfies all the time like it's it's
the same equivalent i that would not no
no sir no this new surgery i've had or
whatever it is then i would feel i would
i would it it's literally as if like
we're watching our partner go and take
another girl out for a meal that's
pretty much it
like or our like partner like standing
in the middle of the street and saying
like look at all this money i have look
at this house i have anyone want to come
spend some time with me that's what
you're doing on instagram yeah that's so
true you ever see a girl like posting an
ass pic and no pictures of her it's her
boyfriend i'm like ladies
what are we what are we doing
and i know what you're thinking oh i
won't just won't post like pictures of
me in my bikini anymore
yeah 100
do not do that like that is that is just
not okay like at all it's not okay in
general to be honest as a woman posting
up photos in your bikini unless you have
a really really valid reason that you're
like a catwalk model and when i say
model i'm not talking about instagram
model and talking about sponsorship
deals
and
i'm not talking about any fans right
you're you're with him you should be
proud to be with him
you know and
quite honestly i think it's either a
case of like completely deleting your
instagram like that's the best thing you
could do like that's going to show that
you have respect for your partner that
like you are all about him right
or
you just don't post things is my youtube
channel a red flag i think it is
just don't post photos of yourself like
you could post a photo of you guys
that's fine or like i don't know your
like cat or something but you're not
gonna do that like i've seen what you
guys are like you're not gonna do that
you're gonna keep posting up photos of
like
looking in the camera in a certain way
we've all done it though right like i'm
100 guilty as well but when you're with
someone especially someone that is high
value that is you know incredibly um
protective over his women it's really
really disrespectful
to happy posting up this kind of content
these types of guys if they if you
continue to do that and they say to you
i don't want you to do that anymore and
you say and you're lucky you got a
warning to be honest most guys if they
see you i won't say most guys any guy
that has options and doesn't feel like
he has to date that like
he's just gonna leave he's not even
gonna tell you why
they're just gonna leave you
and then what you're gonna do you're
gonna be stuck with your little
instagram attracting low value guys and
we all know the ones right we have
like we have guys in our direct messages
all the time all the time the whole time
we don't even read them right like we're
just not even reading them i do not get
that many messages i'm not even gonna
lie i get a couple
here and there but it is not as crazy as
some girls you are to lose
this guy
this high value guy that makes you feel
great
over your instagram yeah it's just not
worth it like if you have a guy that you
really really love and want to spend the
rest of your life with
is is instagram worth it it's not even
that good of an app to be honest like
tick tock is way more fun and you'll
just be left alone with your phone in
your instagram in your pajamas
wasting your best years so
that's just my little take on that i
don't think it's
i don't think instagram's the way
forward for you especially if you've got
if you've got a high value guy in your
life anyway if you don't agree or you
agree
please like and subscribe leave it in
the comments
okay guys you should go subscribe to her
channel she's almost at a thousand subs
let's get her monetized let's get her
monetized okay
all right guys do not forget to
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification bell
and i will talk to you guys next time
all right you guys know i'm that's only
for i'm not leaving like that's only so
i can
so i can um
tick-tock is the worst okay well i don't
care i love tik-tok um
um
better bachelor
okay this is going to be my last video i
think
oh god these are all too long does
anyone else have anything else
oh you're so good
you're such a good doggy we needed to do
reactions with her more
how to get past rejection
okay
uh
okay
okay i'm gonna
okay
you ready
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting with my dog ellie to how
to get past rejection before i start
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification bell
the way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos and if you have watched
two or more of my videos and you do not
subscribe we have beef beef okay hit the
subscribe button it's like right right
below the video right there
also follow my instagram just dot pearly
things like my username is just a dot
after just
[Music]
after multiple attempts of trying to
find girls to reject us we have finally
found a handful of ladies that made us
work for their phone numbers i'm cody
strong from angry picnic here with that
was epic and this is how to get past
rejection
can you tell the viewers like how to
come how how to come back
thank you so much guys for the donation
thank you for the donation okay um my
sound board i'm at 170 dollars of the
500 sound board
so at 500 i'm gonna do a sound board and
i'm gonna have girls on my team come
over and we're gonna do um
like talks and these girls are from all
over the world they're from all over
they're from japan
germany like all these really cool
places but i don't have a sound board
and i can't afford it it's like 500
bucks
so
if you guys
help me get there i will reward you with
great content so i'm gonna start this
over just because i just ruined the
whole
clip okay
i gotta redo it so i'm sorry
okay
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to how to get past
rejection
by
angry picnic before i start don't forget
to subscribe to the channel and bring
that notification bell today i'm going
to be reacting with my little pupper
um
and if you guys have watched two or more
of my videos and you do not subscribe me
and you have beef you already know go
follow my instagram just dot pearly
things just dot pearly thanks
[Music]
after multiple attempts of trying to
find girls to reject us we have finally
found a handful of ladies that made us
work for their phone numbers i'm cody
strong from angry picnic here with that
was epic and this is how to get past
rejection
can you tell the viewers like how to
come how how to come back from rejection
or what to say after a girl says okay i
know nobody asks for my opinion i'm
gonna give it to you
if a girl rejects you it is all about
how you respond it is not about you
getting rejected
and i was talking about this with my
friend gabby how
we have been like madly in love with a
guy that we rejected initially and it
was all because he did not get butt hurt
and was like oh no you rejected me
that's giving us all the power and
saying our opinion matters like if
you're just confident and like act like
her opinion doesn't matter because it
doesn't i'm one girl and you have no
idea why i rejected you you have no idea
it could be because like i'm still you
know it could because she's not over her
ex it could be because she's
i don't know like
just talking to someone that she's
really interested like you have no idea
why
and it doesn't mean you're a plan b
either it just
like sometimes the timing is just off
sorry okay i have a boyfriend you give
up well give me 15 seconds because i'm
actually going the other way 15 seconds
right now okay
right here okay
170 oh my gosh so now i'm at 190. thank
you so much for the donations
190
190 190. oh my gosh 195. thank you guys
thank you so much
oh my gosh because my goal is 500 so i'm
at 195 out of the 500 sound board
you're gorgeous i'm gorgeous so we just
need to wrap this up i get your number
we go on a beautiful date later do you
see do you see how he kept going
like he kept going
and he was just like what like whatever
beautiful day later so a lot of people
tell us that they have boyfriends and
then we and then we persist and then get
the number anyways
so do they do it because they feel bad
some girls might yeah some girls might
be like oh he's actually like and here's
another thing sometimes we're not
attracted to you like at first but
sometimes it's something when a guy
talks and he shows like he's confident
and charismatic like i'm telling you i
have been like the guy that i was like
obsessed with in college i really didn't
know if i liked him at first
and
yeah like i'm telling you i'm telling
you guys i know the manosphere says oh
she looks at you as a plan b
oh she doesn't have that genuine desire
i am telling you i'm telling you
i have had genuine desire
for a guy that i was like
no at first and it's all because of how
he responded
he didn't get oh no like
okay
trying
i'll give you that number i might have a
boyfriend in a different state
yeah well
i might be gay he might be gay but you
know these are just things that we might
have oh gosh so we don't have to worry
about him
do you see he didn't care he did not
care he was like okay so
and what
just
worry about right now in the moment
okay what's your number eight one six
eight one six eight seven two off the
top of your head is there any advice two
ten
two hundred and ten dollars
oh my gosh thank you guys
thank you so much oh my gosh this is
making my day i'm gonna cry
i am going to cry
and being i'm gonna cry thank you um and
being funny also helps like if you guys
take a rejection and turn it into a joke
oh my gosh
you can give that all um no pick-up
lines not like some stupid pick-up
oh my gosh
oh my gosh
is that 220 or 230 i just lost count i
just lost can't wait i was at 150 at the
beginning of this live i was at 150 for
the sound board
and then
170 180 90
195
1
195
205 215
215 225 235
oh my god thank you guys so much
thank you
don't do that if you just like came up
and we're like hey like um i think
you're kind of cute like would you mind
like going to get lunch with me
sometimes compliments but did i stop
going live for a second i'm still live
right
okay i'm still alive i just want to make
sure
not to
not something like super
like sexual yeah sexual that's
definitely good what's your name
charlotte charlotte my swan nice to meet
you you're hot we should uh
we should meet up sometime and make out
oh um it's very forward
i actually have a boyfriend i'm sorry
i was sarcastic but uh oh okay
i was hoping i mean oh you were hoping i
was being serious no it's hoping that
you're being successful
yeah do you see how he's like bantering
with her we love a good banter
a good banter makes us fall in love i
swear to god i swear to god for you a
little bit
how about the coffee
do you still have a boyfriend i mean
the coffee is fine
okay
um sure
seven
thank you so much i don't know what dkk
is i don't know what the conversion is
hold on let me let me
let me convert it so i can cuz i'm at
235
um
dkk to
um
also if you want to send a donation to
my paypal it's hannah h-a-n-n-a-h
perl p-e-a-r-l davis d-a-v-i-s gmail.com
okay to dollars
um
conversion
calculator sorry i know i'm ruining this
this is going to be a tough duh
um
so us dollars is what okay so that's
maybe like 235
we'll just guess so like that's a third
so it's like five bucks so 240. okay
thank you thank you so much 240 240.
thank you
um
500 is the goal to get the sound board
okay
75 confidence is key like if a guy came
if a guy came out today i was like oh
hey but if guy was like hey how are you
doing like you look really pretty today
and they had confidence i'd be more like
that but to them don't you get told
you're pretty like by every guy like
isn't that like boring to hear
no not in person like we don't we don't
get approached in person as much as you
guys think i look homeless half the time
so it's my own damn fault but so okay i
mean a girl might not say like oh thank
you like that really made my day but on
the inside they're probably thinking
like oh my gosh she thinks i'm pretty
you're gorgeous thanks what how do you
exist
wait wait wait i have to talk to you
what's your name marissa i'm hi i'm cody
nice to meet you all right 15 seconds
and that's a good way i learned this in
sales so how we said like 15 seconds
because when you talk to us
i'm nervous because i'm like oh my god
is this man gonna bother me and like not
leave me alone like that's that's what
we're thinking okay so if you come up
just and say hey hey just really quick i
think you're pretty let's go on a date
something like that
yeah you're 15 seconds try not to seem
like you're coming out just try to like
relate to them so like try to like not
even act like you're picking them up for
them yes and go and find out about them
your name's eresa yes what is that the
fraption okay
this is perfect because i want to buy
you a frappuccino later
as a date let's take you at starbucks
classic coffee date i bought you
frappuccino
classic store you fall in love with me
it's so simple yeah i don't know if i
have time anytime soon i'm busy okay
roll you know we'll figure that out like
i'll text you and we'll figure out a
time
because this could be magical
let's not feed around the bush it could
be magical i don't know
me neither so let's figure it out i'll
get your number i'll text you
and then you'll decide whether or not
i'm like the perfect manner okay
okay
uh what's your number um
seven six six most girls just one and
this is a comment you're nervous in 2022
try being a guy and having to deal with
me too yeah guys bro there's always
gonna be obstacles women are not easy to
get like if they're easy to get there
wouldn't be thousands and thousands of
like
dollars put into like courses and [ __ ]
like that wouldn't
exist but but [ __ ] is hard okay
so that's going to be an obstacle yeah
but
i saw this guy where this feminist was
like coming up to him and being like why
are you asking women questions dead on
the street and he literally just called
her pretty and he's like
and she was completely disarmed like you
can't react to the girls that are like
crazy because if you react you are
giving them the power
you and i know it's hard i worked in
sales sometimes i wanted to die
because i would get rejected so much and
it was really hard but i'm telling you i
want to feel like someone's just trying
to talk to them and not hit on them you
know i feel like i'm more attracted to
someone who's just trying to be my
friend your boyfriend doesn't let you
have friends
katie come on i'm really planning
katie
you're gonna shut me down like that okay
i get your number i text you
and if you don't
if you don't respond then i don't i
don't text again okay okay
what's your what's your number seven two
oh seven two
he
she's mad he didn't approach her look at
her her arms are crossed two three six
is offering a coffee date creepy or is
that something that you'd like
back in the day people got asked out to
like dinners and stuff like that like
guys have gotten so cheap like now it's
just coffee you don't even get to wine
and dine me like
like now it's just coffee excuse me
ladies but i was just wondering if you
all three would like to join me as i
fine dine and drink some wine like all
three of us on one date yeah
um i don't think so okay well to be
honest i just wanted her to go on a date
with me but like
i figured that she'd probably say no
because she's with all her friends and
i'd rather like hang out with her with
all three of you than not at all so all
right well i think i could just get your
number probably not i'm really busy okay
well i'm sorry
just give me one chance and that's all i
need and trust me you're going to be
like whoa this was a phenomenal date
yeah
okay all right 9.9 did you see
do you see how he responded
he wasn't whiny he wasn't like oh please
or like he didn't he didn't go backwards
and like
like like his body language was like
okay whatever like he he acted like he
didn't even hear her
and his tonality your tonality is so
important
your tonality is so important like if
you
and it's hard and i noticed this when i
was in sales like if someone would say
no and i just said okay well why is that
or like i was just like
i just kept asking questions
um like people
people would be a lot more receptive
than if i was like oh
okay
like that's
i don't know then you kind of seem like
a [ __ ]
two one two that's one thing girls are
just super weird
okay
and anything else you'd like to say
yeah i think that's pretty much it thank
you for watching the video make sure to
head on over to that was epic's channel
to check out the video we did together
don't forget to subscribe and i'll see
you next time
yeah how many this guy's gotta have a
lot of subs 2.7 million okay guys i
don't even know if i'm gonna be able to
clip this because i i got so excited
about donations but
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification bell
the way you're gonna be notified of my
daily videos and i will talk to you guys
next time
okay
um
should i do one more i have to get to
practice it's 5 30 right now at 6 10 i
need to be at the train station to go to
practice do you think i got one more in
me
thank you guys so much for all these
donations i'm getting so close to the
sound board
it's two i'm at two about 235 dollars i
think it's about 500
and um
once i get and even if it's not if it's
like 600 i've been telling you guys 500
so once i get to 500 i'm gonna buy the
sound board and i'm gonna have
girls from all over the world come and
talk to me
in my apartment
and we're going to talk about different
like red pill topics and i'm so excited
and i really want to do this
so
yeah
okay
so thank you so much so so so much
oh my gosh ellie i'm gonna do one more
just because these donations have been
fire like literally fire
like
i can't i can't not give you guys one
more if
with the the freaking
i mean how much during this stream like
you guys are awesome like that is so
nice that is so nice of you guys to send
that stuff like actually
like i i watch youtubers all the time
and i
occasionally send donations so i know
it's like it genuinely means a lot
um
the okay so ellie stop licking my arm
you're cute though
okay
why did i do that
um
that was epic
hey excuse me
uh let's see
uh
what else should i do i need one quick
quick quick quick
pin your paypal in the chat okay
my paypal it's gonna be a weird name
it's like called hap system because i'm
i need to change it it's my old job
oh wait actually i should
do hannahpearldavis
gmail.com i'm gonna put paypal in it
paypal
um
pin message
bro i know i know like donating takes a
lot because you guys get this content
for free regardless so every donation
i appreciate like so much because i know
you guys like you do not have to do that
at all
so every donation like it really gets me
going and it makes me so much more
excited to make content because like it
just tells me i'm doing something right
and i genuinely believe in this like if
i can get this sound board i genuinely
believe that i can make such a good show
and it's gonna be like once a week
probably like sundays or some some night
of the week i can get the girls to come
and it's gonna be fun it is going to be
fun
okay okay i'm gonna do one more
i want to do what was that channel
before that i looked up uh
what was the one with the guy asking
questions i really liked that one
um
what was the one with the guy asking
questions
um
[Music]
i i really didn't want to stream today i
like swear to god i wasn't going to
stream because i was like kind of in a
bad mood because
i'm sad um
and then i was like you know what i'm
going to just i'm going to stream for a
little bit
and if i
if i if i don't want to do it after like
half hour then i'll stop
and [ __ ] i made
i gotta stop swearing but i made
like over 50 bucks on this stream like
you guys are amazing like you're
literally amazing
um
okay guys put something in the chat put
something in the chat
um
oh let's go to it's complicated that's
what i want
okay this is going to be my last video
um
let's do one of their more popular ones
so
social media when it benefits them okay
let's do this one i think
this is a little long i might have to
cut it early but okay i'm gonna do my
intro you guys know
okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel today i'm
gonna be reacting to what it benefits to
them the rules of modern dating and
understanding women it's complicated
today i'm reacting with my dog
before i start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification bell
if you have watched two or more of my
videos and you do not subscribe me and
you we have what beef beef
swear to god beef okay also follow my
instagram just dot pearly things just
dot pearly thanks
also
consider
donating to the channel for a sound
board it's hannah pearl davis
h-a-n-n-a-h
p-e-a-r-l-d-a-v-i-s gmail.com and it is
um that's my paypal so
thank you so much five dollars thank you
oh my god thank you so much i'm at 240.
i'm almost halfway to the sound board
oh i'm so close
what would you think would be the best
and worst thing about being a woman
uh the best thing about being a woman is
uh you have tits
and uh you have you actually have like a
lot more opportunity so like if there's
like opportunity for like using your
body and stuff like that you know like
guys don't have that opportunity like
girls don't like seeing your dick
um guys like seeing your tits so i think
that's a bonus yeah that's really true
um and i noticed it when i got a sales
job because all the guys would say that
i got extra help because i'm a girl and
i was like no i'm not it's because i'm
fun i'm friendly but then later in life
i realized it probably was because i was
a girl um worst thing about being a
woman is they're not funny at all
um i think their jokes are [ __ ] um and
if they think that they're funny they're
probably like a five out of ten funny
okay funny i'm hilarious get out of here
girls are powerful girls are strong girl
boss you can do whatever you want be a
strong woman
okay um
are beautiful women more privileged or
disadvantaged by their looks
okay well they're definitely both but
thank you for asking that well let me
let me ask you guys beautiful women oh
my gosh okay they're the victims of
their own privilege
beautiful women get too many options at
those options it's usually like a top
guy so they don't always like treat them
right
i mean there's definitely disadvantages
but i mean if the privileges didn't
outweigh the disadvantages would any
woman ever bother getting plastic
surgery
well see that's the thing i
had a reduction of my breasts they're
still large and
i still get too much attention
and that's why i
got rid of them
but being attractive you still always
get
attention from men and i don't know how
to say
you don't want it because you don't want
it
but then you do want it right
right well let me ask this would you
be willing to give up the occasional
unwanted attention
catcalling harassment if it meant you
never got any attention whatsoever or
special treatment from men exactly
that's the whole key because
no i love special treatment
no
no keep it coming please
exactly i hate the attention
but then when i
feel unattractive
and i don't get the attention it's like
[Music]
i don't love that either so wouldn't
that be like saying i want to be a
celebrity but i never want to deal with
paparazzi exactly well i'm just saying
it's not like saying i want all the
privileges without any of the
accountability that comes with it
exactly well isn't that having your cake
and eating it too yup okay but is that
is that
fair
no and that's what i hate about all of
it because that's what's so hard about
raising a child too where i'm like
it's not about looks and
if there was one thing you wish men
understood better about women what would
it be
i would say
the fact that there really is an orgasm
gap and
men need to
men need to understand that and realize
that
when
you have to get so uncomfortable talking
about that stuff
guys are probably gonna get off but
girls it's a lot harder for us to do
that so they need to understand that and
and own that
why do women expect men to be good in
bed if getting laid is such a hard thing
for men to acquire
oh
that's a great question that's a great
thank you for that someone just sent ten
dollars to my paypal thank you so much
we are at
2 35. i think i'm doing the math right
245
245 i'm almost halfway there oh my gosh
five dollars and i'm halfway to the
sound board this [ __ ] rules the world
why do women often talk about how they
secretly run the world but then also
complain about how they're so oppressed
yeah that i don't get because i don't
think women secretly run the world
um
i think we're girl bosses when we want
to be of course
but
no we don't run the world some women we
don't why do we act like we do we do not
we do not at all complain about the fact
that we live in a man's world because
how hard it is to live in a man's world
because
we try to give up enough credit they
don't give us enough credit that's true
i agree they don't give us enough credit
how much is enough credit like what do
you want men to do that they're not
doing already
i feel like
okay here's the thing if you are a good
leader
you do not care about the credit and
this is where my dad my dad is brilliant
brilliant my dad he is um
he owns a software company and he he's
very very successful and successful
people do not give a [ __ ] about the
credit as long as the work gets done and
they get paid
so they are so willing like he
understood that if you make your
employees like want like feel like even
if you do most of the work if you make
your employees feel like they did do you
get more out of them
ask the question again
you mentioned that men don't give women
enough credit so i'm asking like what
specifically are you not getting from
men that you want like as far as credit
like what do you want as far as
you know
being hold us a title to things like
we're only supposed to
you know be at home and do only cooking
and cleaning and and stuff like that and
it's why do we look at that as we have
to we get to guys
if you need to be a stay-at-home wife
and mother
bro bro
you that's a privilege that's a pr that
is such a privilege oh my gosh that's a
privilege half of the [ __ ] we have to do
is
it
actually women that can go out here and
do the same thing that men do you know
so i just feel like but we can't we
don't make as much money statistically
they hold us a title our title is so low
but without us they wouldn't know what
to do they would not know what to do and
i feel like you know what to do as far
as what
like how
yes like how
us women can
take
different things and put it together as
far as meal wise like cooking and
cleaning and watching the kids you
cannot find a man that can do all that
because they but hold on oh my gosh
if i didn't have to worry about bills
you can find a million guys that would
be fine i promise i mean aren't there
there are men who are chefs and there
are men who you know are single dads so
i mean it is possible that's true but
with a woman is going to come natural
with that man he's going to ask
questions do you think beautiful women
are more privileged or disadvantaged by
their looks
i think they're more privileged by their
looks 100 i think a look and take a girl
a long way i think the the way that girl
uses her looks can bring her far away in
life 100 but i think i i genuinely think
women that
it's like too much power at such a young
age and this is what you guys don't
understand about men and women men get
power later in life but women get it
immediately and we are forced to make
decisions that will impact the rest of
our life very young
very young so like a girl that's 16 if
she is stunning and from the age of 16
she gets all this attention
what does she do with that attention
like
at 16 she's given the opera or at 18 she
turns 18 she's given the opportunity to
do an only fans
and make millions of dollars
and she's expected to turn that down and
she should right that's not
it's not good she should but like that
is a lot of temptation for someone to
have so young
does a woman's level of physical
attractiveness affect her behavior and
potential for status yeah 100 i think uh
some girls like mike get ahead of their
cells they might get egotistical about
it um some ways that they might act
uh if they're like better looking they
might think that they're like on a
higher class and they might look for
things that are like better which is
obviously good because like if you're
like a good looking guy you probably
look for the same thing we literally get
paid to take pictures with people right
you know we get free rides stuff like
that i ride like free yeah
daily i get free stuff daily like free
weed free everything you can ask me to
get anything and this is the thing we
hate on women for this a lot in the red
pill but but this is the thing
would you do better with it if you
turned 18 okay
if you if you turned 18 and you had the
opportunity to be a millionaire just
based on your looks or even you know
make a hundred thousand bucks whatever
it is
and would you be wise enough to spend it
and invest it properly like that that's
just a lot for someone to have so young
i don't have to give up vagina i don't
have to kiss nobody i don't have to do
nothing i don't have to work i literally
make my rent off taking pictures of
people i really walk down the street i
get hella free rides hella free [ __ ] i
literally just got paid two hundred
dollars to sweep him up a house today
just because i was pretty
and men just don't get that right but a
man can be cute as [ __ ]
well tell me this then like with all
those privileges that you just listed
that so many women you know have access
to why do you think there are so many
women who complain about just how
difficult it is to be a woman in our
society
because [ __ ] are
i feel like women think that it's hard
to be
like to be in our society under mine no
yeah [ __ ] are just hella like
we're like we're spoiled like i went to
a crab shack today and i'm used to
having like people open my crab for me
and i literally had to open my own legs
and i was like what the [ __ ] like you
know we're just so spoiled we get
everything we want whenever we want
you shouldn't have to open your legs you
should be able to keep your legs closed
oh yeah i always keep my head i get
everything your crab legs not your legs
legs
no i know i'm kidding okay
they don't take them seriously because
they looking at the fact that they are
beautiful and they're not understanding
that they also have a brain now they're
not understanding that they also have
something to contribute as far as
knowledge-wise you're looking at them
having beauty and you're not realizing
that they have more to offer okay but
here's the thing okay there are
definitely disadvantages i will agree
with you on that but if beautiful women
were not more privileged would any woman
ever bother getting plastic surgery
facts facts you have a point you did
have so the privileges absolutely
outweigh the disadvantages
and who's more likely to get plastic
surgery men or women women women okay so
obviously a woman okay so let me ask you
this does a woman's level of physical
attractiveness affect her behavior and
potential for status
yes it does how
because
okay so the fact the reason why is
because
men have a shallow mind mindset now i'm
not talking down on me because we need
men as well we need women and we need
men we need a balance but they have a
shallower mindset i feel like and a lot
of times the actual physical view is
more important to them than the mental
view well what they say is they say men
fall in love with their eyes women fall
in love with their ears do you ever hear
that expression yes i agree with that
inspiration i love a sweet talker a
little too much okay now here's the
thing okay would you agree that men
objectify women sexually yes okay would
you also agree that women also tend to
objectify men financially
yes yes okay because men are success
objects women are sex objects women are
beauty objects correct
is it harder to create or to maintain
value
is it harder to create
or maintain value
i feel like they're both equally
obtainable they're equally obtainable is
the pressure greater on men to be
successful or on women to be beautiful
oh
that's a good question
oh my gosh i don't even i know i
that's a good question i'll say
definitely that's equal that's equal
well don't nope it's not equal actually
because a woman she mostly just has to
provide sex for you for the most part
well don't men typically have to create
their success while women just have to
maintain their beauty
i mean are men typically born with the
muscles money and status that attract
most women
uh not every man because even me like i
was um pretty thin malnutrition so not
every man but just select few definitely
so then aren't women born with inherent
value while men have to create their
value from scratch uh
are women born with value
unless you're just tall then you're
considered valuable i mean aren't your
average like your average man is more
likely to find your average woman
attractive than your average woman will
find your average man attractive is
isn't that true
yeah that's definitely true now okay so
aren't women born with
you know the natural assets that attract
most men but men aren't typically born
with the natural assets that attract
most women yeah because for the most
part if a woman throws some coochies she
throws some little head at you and she's
going to she's going for the most part
win
if all women should be considered
beautiful
interesting
does that mean that all men can be
successful
all women
no no that definitely would not be able
to happen right but we do say that all
women are beautiful so why don't we say
that all men are successful oh
that is a great point that is a great
point
i guess yeah it's not fair it's not it's
not equal it's the double standard
how do nightclubs get away with charging
men a higher admission fee than women
isn't that sexist oh i agree i always
wondered like why women get in for free
like i think that is definitely a double
standard i definitely agree i think like
there should be a men's night as well
and so like like women's are they're
normally thursdays right
and i think there should be a men's
night as well okay and so if private
companies can get away with that type of
sexism why shouldn't private companies
get away with a gender pay gap
oh
bro
these are great points
see that's hard because
yeah
i just don't think you can base
wage of worth ethic
on
gender
i don't think it's sexist i think i
think the fact that girls can get in
more keeps it from being a sausage fest
i know all guys would want to go to the
club and they'd want to have more girls
there than guys so i feel like it
attracts more guys when they see hot
females so it's a marketing tactic if
anything so it makes sense
don't you think women would complain if
they were the ones expected to pay more
yeah
yeah for sure i mean i think if i was a
man i would probably be a little bit
upset about that too to be completely
honest if private companies can get away
with that type of sexism why shouldn't
private companies get away with a gender
pay gap
that is a good question
i think that it really it comes down to
accountability on all parts right like
we recognize that there's a problem in
equality with men and women and whether
that's women benefiting getting into
clubs for free or men benefiting getting
paid more i think that conversation
starts with us admitting that there's a
problem and everybody owning it like
let's
live in this world together as equals
and both sides need to step up to the
table and do the work that it takes to
be recognized so why do the people who
say they want equality only complain
about the double standards that don't
benefit them
can you elaborate on that more
well i'll just repeat the question
so why do the people who say they want
equality only complain about the double
standards that don't benefit them
i don't know i would say i'm someone who
is for equality and like i said like
last night like we were able to get into
clubs for free and do a lot of things
that guys probably wouldn't be able to
do but
we're here advocating for equality on
both sides so i think i don't believe in
equality
i don't like men and women are not the
same really depends on the person you
talk to well how well how likely are you
going to see a woman in a club saying in
the name of fairness i demand that you
charge me full price
i mean i think if you flip that question
like you're not gonna see a man who's
getting paid a hundred thousand dollars
a year compared to women a woman who's
getting paid seventy five thousand
dollars a year you're not going to see
that guy demanding that she gets paid
the equal amount so i feel like that
flips on both sides but don't you see
men going to women's marches you know
supporting women's issues
um i think on and off i think it depends
on so aren't there already men out there
like kind of fighting for equality for
women
why are you more likely to see men
fighting for women's issues than you see
women fighting for men's facts straight
facts women do not care i say this stuff
to girls all the time i'll be like
that's a man's issue that's a man's
issue that's a man's issue women do not
care they don't it's all about them it's
always about issues
men fight for women's issues do they
well don't men go to women's marches and
identify as feminists i've never seen it
there are plenty of men actually who
love to see it
so you've never you've never seen a man
at a woman's march
you've never seen a male feminist
um i've heard of it but i would love to
see oh my god i see men's feminist
male feminists all the time all the time
i wish i saw less hey
why don't women just start identifying
as men to get higher pay and men start
identifying as women in order to get
free drinks at ladies nights at the rate
america's going that wouldn't surprise
me
gender pay gap i think uh like i said
before girls have equal opportunity i
think there's a lot of ways that girls
can make uh pay other ways
um yeah i
i definitely do not think that i think
women are at an advantage in making
money especially when you're young other
than like jobs and stuff if he has an
old woman you probably are at a
disadvantage but as a young woman you're
in a lot of like other places like if
they have a good looking whatever they
can make like a lot more money somewhere
like in other places so i think okay
does the fact that only fans exist prove
that women are okay being objectified as
long as they're getting paid
yeah because i think there's a double
standard there because it's like a lot
of girls that say oh like they're like
all this and they're like oh like all
about like feminism whatever blah blah
and that they're like super important
but then they put themselves out there
and they think like oh i'm gonna show my
body all that [ __ ] and like you're
basically putting yourself there and
saying like
i'm basically like not all that not all
of what i'm saying
if private companies can get away with
that type of sexism why shouldn't
private companies get away with a gender
pay gap
there's not a gender pay cap that's
complete [ __ ]
is sex i agree there's not it's about
the it's about the industries that women
choose women do not choose the highest
paying industries catch me dad before i
want to be an accountant or work in
finance no no sir no ma'am she says i'm
only bad when it happens to women
or engineering i'd rather die than be an
engineer no definitely not because
brothers make more than me and it's not
because there was sexism is because i
wanted to go on youtube
um
i wanted to work in media and sales and
my brothers wanted to be engineers they
make more money sexism can go both ways
the same with racism like not only white
people can be racist and black people
black people can also be racism to white
people so it's like i think i think it
go both ways
is sexism only bad when it happens to
women
i don't really know a guy that cares if
sexism happens so
yes and no but
i don't think i think every guy
currently is like yeah
brilliant
a man can give you a house but a woman
gives you a home
a man can give you i don't know what we
can say on this but a man can give you
sperm but a woman can give you a child
a man can give anything that a man gives
a woman would make it greater
what that's not a good point
that's not a good point
you can give us anything we will make it
greater you can give us groceries what
about a car
oh we run our cars into the ground oh my
gosh you're telling me we take care of a
house better than men get out we will
make a meal
you can give us
you can give us i'm gonna make more than
my brothers if you stay on youtube god i
hope so please send a donation oh my
gosh please guys please
respectfully you don't have to but like
respectfully
we make a trip i don't know
that wasn't that good who is responsible
for pregnancy the man or the woman
both
okay
why do women claim to be the creator
okay this is where i disagree
women and men are both responsible if
you nut and a girl that is your own
fault if you get her pregnant but on the
same token women we have like how many
forms of birth control condoms tracking
your cycle iud like
bro if you get pregnant it's your own
damn fault haters of life when the child
is wanted but when the pregnancy is
unplanned it suddenly becomes the man's
fault for not wearing a condom
i don't have that mentality so i can't
relate right i mean it's both consensual
you know you
literally let a guy
go inside you knowing that the
possibility is
yeah i don't i don't think like that so
men are probably more responsible than
women
as far as birth is concerned because a
man can impregnate one woman
a man can impregnate nine women within
one month a woman can only be pregnant
one time within one month so honestly i
feel like birth control should be in a
man's hands that's just my opinion what
but they don't have it okay but don't
women
don't women ultimately decide who gets
sex and who gets born that's correct we
ultimately decide who gets sex and who
gets born but a man can impregnate more
can impregnate nine women in one day
have to say at the end of the day it
would be the woman me personally because
she has to make the decisions just
either keep the baby or abort the baby
well aren't women ultimately the ones
who decide who gets sex and who gets
born
yes for the most part yes
okay
why do women claim to be the creators of
life when the child is wanted but when
the pregnancy is unplanned it suddenly
becomes the man's fault for not wearing
a condom
this goes back to the first segment a
lot of women don't want to take
accountability for their own actions
that's the truth
yeah look guys
we don't
oh gosh wrong one if we can blame other
people for stuff sorry this angle is
kind of ass i'm gonna try to do a better
one next time but
i
i need to end the stream because i have
to go to volleyball practice but thank
you guys so freaking much for all the
donations oh wait don't forget to
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification bell and i'll talk to you
guys next time okay i have to do that
clip end
guys thank you so guys so damn much i
made today i think i made 245 so i'm
halfway to the sound board i got 150
donation this morning or this guy paid
me to go on his channel right so 150
bucks and then i made 135 in this stream
like i i appreciate it that is going to
be such a good show and when we get to
this when we get to this um
when we get to the goal
when we get to the goal it's going to be
a such a cool show like i'm going to
bring girls on from all over the world
i'm going to bring them to my apartment
we are going to do
such a cool show so if you haven't
please consider